we're going to start
these are the this is the very first
lecture uh associated with um
the book introduction to applied linear
algebra vectors matrices and least
squares
and we're going to jump right in now at
the very beginning
which is vectors uh so we'll start by
talking a little bit about the
uh notation so we'll talk about notation
uh we'll go on
then and i'll say a little bit about
examples and
we'll talk a little bit about adding
the first first set of operations on
vectors but first we're just going to
talk about vectors themselves
okay so a vector
is just an ordered list of numbers uh so
and it's usually it's written
will use in in the book in the course um
two notations for that um so you can
either write it
uh vertically uh as an array of numbers
stacked on top of each other
or you can write it in line like this
and and
these are reasonably unif these are
reasonably standard uh
notations um so um
up here you'd see the conventional ones
which is where we uh
these are the this is where we denote it
as a stacked uh list
um and we'll see later that these are
called column vectors but that that's
another story
um so these are this is a vector um
and we do and it's i should have
mentioned it it's uh it's a little bit
it's not casual here right that uh right
we use commas here
and we don't use uh we don't use
semicolons or something and
and so on and there's no notation in in
the stacked column things okay
now that's what a vector is so this is a
this is a vector uh here
uh and three different ways you can see
to write it like this
this or that okay now
the numbers uh in in the in the vector
uh in in these lists um those are called
uh entry they're called elements so the
elements of the vector
the entries coefficients or components
so these are the these are the words
that would be used to describe and all
of these are used
used widely to this guide disguise to
describe the entries
so for example you would say that the
second component of this vector
is zero right you would say that
it's fourth entry is minus
7.2 right so that's how you would refer
to that
now the number of elements in in a
vector that's called its
size although maybe a better name to say
it because later we're going to have a
concept of size of a vector
so to be less confusing maybe a better
term is dimension or
length so you would say that this vector
which i've now written three different
ways for this three
ways to denote this vector you would say
that its dimension
is four right and so that's the idea
um and if you have a vector of size n
where n is an integer like one
two three four uh then you refer to that
as an n vector
okay so so the vector described by these
any of these three equivalent notations
that's a four
vector as people call it right now a
a one vector um so i should say that
the numbers inside are called scalars i
mean they're just numbers right but
they're called scalars right
and although we're not gonna for us the
scalars are gonna be real
real numbers like minus 1.1 or pi
or um 3.267
that they're going to be numbers like
that now it is possible
and there are applications where the
entries are for example complex numbers
right we won't encounter those but that
it's not hard to extend what we do to
the case where the entries are are
complex numbers
and so for us these are called scale
scalars
okay now
we can't just we don't just write down
vectors with numerical entries
um a lot of times our discussion is
they're going to be abstract
and so then what that means is you're
going to use a symbol to note a vector
and there's lots of ways to do that so
for example
here's a lowercase a and and that's
meant to denote a vector
uh or capital x or p or beta or e
superscript ought uh actually i don't
know what that is i presume
is a mnemonic for whatever that is
supposed to be
um and this there's some other
conventions so here
we don't we're we're going to use a
method where we just write these out and
they're vectors now in some fields in
some areas
people do things like well in fields
where a vector isn't like a fancy thing
they consider them fancy and they might
do things like write them in bold
or with an arrow on top so so you see
this and this and
you might see that in physics or
mechanical engineering or some other
areas
where you know for whatever historical
reasons they like to
remind you in the notation that
something is a vector
um but we're not going to do that but
we're going to we're going to just write
them as
you know a lower case a capital x that
kind of thing
now when you have abstract notation the
question is how do you refer to an entry
of a vector
and that's done this way with
subscripting right so
if a is a vector an n vector then
uh you would have you would denote the
ith entry element
or coefficient is going to be a sub i
right
obviously here i goes from 1 to n
if you if you have a 4 vector and you
say what's a sub 5 the answer is
it has no it's meaningless right so um
that that that's the idea of what it
what what it means so
this is how we're going to denote an
entry as by a sub
i um and so for example
let's go back to our vector here uh here
so we would say if if this vector if we
call that
a then for example a 2 is equal to
0.0 okay which i guess is just zero
um so that's what a2 is that's that's
how you refer to that
um okay um
okay so here uh the i in a sub i
um is uh called the index
and the index because it's an index into
the vector it tells me
you know where where do i find you know
the eif element and whatever anyway so
it's it's
traditionally called an index um and
by the way this is just a convention but
we typically use as
indices and this is following long
actually centuries
of mathematical tradition is that
indexes are typically
denoted by i j k
l these are just conventions you can use
anything you like to denote an index but
these are
these are the traditional ones um and
then vectors
you know are typically denoted a b c or
you know it could be uh you know p
q uh you know z y u v th these kinds of
things
and again these are just pure
conventions there's nothing
you can use anything to denote a vector
okay
so i is going to be the the the index um
um now uh as i said uh in
so-called mathematical notation you
index a vector from
from i equals 1 to n so a so if a is a
vector a sub 1 is
what we would say is the first entry and
a sub n is the last entry or something
like that
um now there's going to be some an
ambiguity in notation
and you know we'll we'll talk about it
when we get there but
sometimes a sub i is not going to mean
the i
element of a single vector a but
actually we're going to be talking about
a list of vectors and a sub i is itself
a vector
we'll talk more about that when we come
to that but it's just something to be
aware
of okay uh
first concept about vectors um
is equality right so what we're gonna do
is if i have two vectors a and b
of the same size we'll say that they're
going to be equal
if all the all the corresponding entries
are the same
okay so that means you know for example
i could write this 1 0 minus one
equals
uh equals uh you know one
zero minus one now that's not a very
exciting
equation there right there um but say a
couple of things about this the first
thing is a concept that we are going to
see
over and over again in this course and
it's the concept of
it's a concept of some of symbol
overloading
um and overloading is a really
interesting
uh concept what it means is that we have
a single symbol which is equality
now you know what equality is you know
for example what it means for two
numbers to be equal
it means that the same number right so
3.1 is 3.1
so that's that's what equality between
two numbers is
but here we're going to use the very
same simple equals
uh the symbol equals and we're going to
use it between two vectors and we're
going to write something like that
right and that doesn't mean the same as
you know 3.1 equals 3.1 right this
this says that vectors a and b are are
equal is what this says
and so um anyway it's just a it's a i
mean it's related you know
good overloading does the following
you see something in a in a symbol or a
concept
that in another that in a simpler
context you understand
like equality we know what it means for
two numbers to be equal
here we just borrow that concept and and
make it hold
and define what it means for vectors
right and so
the idea is you know it should be kind
of very natural so that's the idea
um actually before we go on i do want to
make one
uh one comment um and that is that
in what i'm describing now is is
is standard mathematical notation and
it's how it's you know
by default that's the language we're
going to be speaking it's just math
okay um actually the notation i'm using
here would be
universally understood throughout not
just pure math but
many many mathematical areas where
people use vectors and
just for the record that's a whole lot
of them okay so so
this is standard mathematical notation
um you really need to be careful and
distinguish that from computer
language notation right so each com many
computer languages or
packages for doing effect for handling
and manipulating vectors
they'll have they'll have different
syntax and so you have to be very
careful you're going to have to learn so
what it means is
none is going to be exactly like the
mathematical one
some will be close they might have
semicolons or something like that but
so what that really means is that well
kind of unfortunately at a very minimum
you're going to want to learn two
notation systems
right one is mathematical notation
that's
that's the standard and the second one
is whichever computer language
you intend to work with to follow along
this way
you'll have to learn uh the language
there and then you'll have to be able to
translate back and forth now
what is absolutely critical is that you
should never be confused
which of these two dialects you're
speaking are you speaking math or are
you
speaking julia or python or whatever it
is you you choose to to use
um so you need to keep those straight in
your minds and don't mix them i mean
that that's
that's actually a very bad thing it
leads to great confusion
okay so that's what a vector is um by
the way at this point i want to be
completely honest
there you should have no interest
whatsoever because well it's not
interesting we haven't said anything
interesting we've just said these are
what vectors are
this is i mean like who cares don't
worry we're going to get to that
in fact i would hope that within by the
end of this particular lecture
you'll at least have some idea that
vectors can be
like could be super interesting in some
applications
okay now we have the concept of block
vectors and
what this means is um if i have uh
three vectors i'm going to call them bc
and d um and they have sizes let's say m
and p again these are sort of standard
mathematical conventions where
things like m and p are typically
dimensions and they're also typically
integers
okay so the stacked vector
or concatenation of the of the vectors
is is denoted simply you just stack them
on top of each other like
this and put brackets around it
and there you go you've got a stack
vector now what this
is is it's a vector obtained by first
putting all the entries of b then the
entries of c
then the entries of d okay so let's just
do a super simple example here
um let me let me stack i'll do it this
way
how about s equals you know minus 1
1 and t is going to be
0 2 2
okay and then i can form the following i
can say that s
stacked on t so let's talk about this
s is a 2 vector right meaning it's got
dimension two
um t is a three vector meaning it's got
dimension
uh three um now the stack here
which is s stacked on top of t this
thing has dimension five
and it is here are the entries it is the
entries from
s right then the entries from t
okay so there's that's s stacked on top
of t that would be sort of the slang
uh you would say or it's a well just a
stacked vector
okay so this is an important concept and
we're going to see later uh
that's going to come up in a whole lot
of applications and it's going to be
kind of interesting it's a way to just
put two vectors together okay
um there are some special vectors that
we're going to talk about
um so a very special vector is the zero
this is the so-called zero vector
um and what we're gonna do is
we are gonna simply write it a zero just
like the number
zero that's strong overloading right so
in this course when you see the symbol
zero
it could mean zero the number
or it could mean a zero twelve vector or
another zero vector of some sort
we'll we'll get to that later but the
idea is so we're going to use the same
symbol just without even thinking about
it is going to represent both
possibly a number or a
a vector itself now if we really want to
say what the size is we'll put a
subscript so
0 if i write 0 sub 3
right then that's the following vector
it's the
3 vector with all entries 0. that's the
that's the 3 vector
okay so we're going to write it that way
now there's another vector this the zero
vector is
absolutely standard throughout all of
mathematics um
and and mathematical applications um now
the next vector that we're going to
encounter is something called what the
one vector or sometimes
the ones vector because if there are
many entries in it
that's the ones vector and uh now that
we are going to distinguish a little bit
and we're going to use this bold
one to represent that right so here here
for example
is one i'll try to make that bold and
this is the
the ones vector of size two and it's
just a two vector with both entries
equal to one
okay so that's the ones vector oh
i should add that you know whatever
computer language you're using
will have operations to create for
example zero vectors and ones vectors
and things like that so
i'm not going to go into that but and
they'll be they'll may be different from
our notation but you'll see something
like that for example it would be ones
of some of five and that would
automatically give you a
ones vector a five vector with all
entries one
okay a unit vector that's nothing that's
going to come up
it's very very uh important concept
that's going to come up a lot
a unit vector is a vector where all
entries are zero
except one and that entry is one so
for example that's a unit vector uh
that is unit a unit three vector so
these three
are are unit vectors uh they are three
vectors meaning they have three entries
their dimension is three
and this is e sub 2 and e sub 2 means
it's the second one and it means that
the entry in that vector that's one is
is two so the second entry the first and
third entry are zero as you can see so
these are unit vectors
right so um again i acknowledge that at
this point
this should mean nothing to you it
should be like all of your other
terrible math classes in the past
you're if you're not thinking why am i
learning this or why should i care about
this
well you should be thinking that okay
but don't worry we're gonna get to it
these are just some very basic notation
stuff and then we'll get into
what you know what they represent and
then later i mean
actually later in the course you can
actually do real stuff with them like
stuff
you couldn't do before and that's kind
of awesome okay
uh one last concept is a sparsity um
for a vector so you say that a vector is
sparse
if a lot of its entries are zero okay
now you know if it's a small vector with
dimension 10 or 20 i mean who cares
right
um but a lot of times we're going to be
messing around with vectors which have a
dimension
like 1 million or 10 million or 100
million i mean
there are plenty of vectors that that
that people deal with
that have those okay so that's an
example
um of those are big vectors right and
sometimes uh all the end you know all
the entries are non-zero or something
like that
but in a lot of applications you
encounter
a vector where like a it's a let's say
it's a one million long vector
but there's only a few hundred entries
that are non-zero
this is very common we're going to get
to some examples and it'll become
completely clear in the examples
when these things come up but that would
be an example anyway a vector that
has most of its entries zero is called
sparse
and there's lots of things you can do
with those i mean the most obvious is
you can store them in a much more
efficient way
instead of storing on a computer you
know
almost a million numbers which are zero
and then a
you know 100 that are not instead of
that what you do is you simply
make a list of you make a data structure
that
that somehow specifies which entries are
non-zero and gives their values and
there's a lot of ways to do that
it's also true that when you do
operations on vectors which we're going
to get to we haven't
seen them yet but when you but when we
get to them those can be done those we
can be performed
quite uh efficiently uh on sparse
vectors uh so uh one concept
for a vector is nnz nnz stands for
number of non-zeros and so
that tells you how many of the entries
in the vector are
non-zero so here here's some sparse
vector here's the smartest vector in the
world
zero because all the entries are zero so
that's a sparse that's a very sparse
vector
um unit vectors that's that's about the
second most
sparse vectors you can have right
because if i say
here is e 17 and it's a hundred vector
that means it's a hundred long vector if
you wrote it out
you'd see 99 zeros and then you know as
the 17th entry you would see a one
and all the others entries would be zero
so that's a sparse vector and you would
say that
nnz of that vector is one it has one
non-zero entry so that's that's the idea